Before our story begins, let's remember how it used to be. Jacky lived in the South Side in a Black neighborhood. City didn't enforce the housing code properly, didn't investigate arsons.
在我们的故事开始之前，先回顾一下过去的情况。杰基住在南区的一个黑人社区。市政当局没有妥善执行住房法规，也没有调查纵火事件。
There would be fires going on in Woodlawn daily, several times a day. And it was just fire engines all the time. And so my daughter started to believe that when buildings got old and died, like people got old and died-- that you knew a building was old and was dying because it would burn up.
伍德朗每天都会发生火灾，一天好几次。到处都是消防车。于是我女儿开始相信，当建筑物变老死去时，就像人变老死去一样——你会知道一栋建筑老了快要死了，因为它会烧起来。
Before our story begins, Chicago was run by the Democratic machine, and Black aldermen, like Danny Davis, would turn out to vote for the machine election after election. But the machine didn't reward the Black wards for those votes the way it paid back the white wards on the North Side with street cleanings and sewers, with newly paved roads and sidewalks, economic development money.
在我们的故事开始之前，芝加哥由民主党机器掌控，像丹尼·戴维斯这样的黑人议员，选举时都会一届接一届地为机器投票。但机器并没有像回报北区的白人选区那样，用街道清洁、下水道工程、铺设新路和人行道以及经济开发资金来回馈黑人选区对这些选票的支持。
Well, actually, we had called the areas colonies. And just basically picking up the garbage in these wards, just trying to keep them clean was a real problem. The person who was elected, there would be so much focus on garbage pickup that you'd almost have to just be the garbage alderman. I recall telling people time and time again that I was tired of just being the garbage alderman.
嗯，事实上，我们曾把这些地区称为殖民地。基本上，仅仅是清理这些选区的垃圾，保持环境整洁就是一个真正的问题。选出来的人，由于对垃圾清理的关注太多，你几乎只能当个“垃圾议员”。我记得曾一次又一次地告诉人们，我厌倦了只当一个垃圾议员。
Before our first story begins, the Chicago political machine squeezed Black kids into mobile trailers behind public schools rather than let them attend white schools just blocks away. Before our story begins, the Chicago machine built high-rise public housing to hold Blacks on the South Side and keep them from moving into white neighborhoods.
在我们第一个故事开始之前，芝加哥政治机器将黑人孩子塞进公立学校后面的移动拖车里，而不是让他们进入仅几个街区之遥的白人学校。在我们故事开始之前，芝加哥机器建造了高层公共住房，把黑人限制在南区，防止他们搬进白人社区。
Before our story begins, the Chicago political machine built a system of highways that coincidentally divided Black neighborhoods from white and particularly insulated the mayor's all-white neighborhood, Bridgeport. Typical inequities-- unemployment in the white 11th Ward was 0%. Unemployment in the 4th Ward, where Blacks lived, was 25%.
在我们故事开始之前，芝加哥政治机器建造了一套高速公路系统，巧合地将黑人社区与白人社区隔离开来，并特别保护了市长全是白人的居住区——布里奇波特。典型的这种不平等——白人第11选区的失业率为0%。而黑人居住的第4选区的失业率则为25%。
This is a story about one ethnic group doing what so many other ethnic groups have done in this country-- put its own candidate in City Hall, won the mayor's office. But because this ethnic group happened to be Black, what happened was unlike anything that happens when an Italian politician or an Irish politician or a Jewish politician take City Hall. White voters deserted their own political party. White politicians tried to stage a public, slow-motion coup. And the mayor faced pressures that were different from those faced by any white mayor of any city in America.
这是一个关于一个族群在我国做着许多其他族群都做过的事情的故事——让自己的候选人进入市政厅，赢得了市长职位。但因为这个族群恰好是黑人，所发生的事情与意大利政客、爱尔兰政客或犹太政客入主市政厅时所发生的一切完全不同。白人选民抛弃了他们自己的政党。白人政客试图发动一场公开的、慢动作的政变。市长所面临的压力，与美国任何城市的任何白人市长所面临的都不同。
And this little parable of race and politics in America does not take place in some distant, pre-civil-rights past. It happened just 10 years ago here in Chicago.
而这个关于美国种族与政治的小寓言，并不是发生在遥远的民权运动之前的过去。它就发生在10年前的芝加哥。
Good evening. You're on with Harold Washington.
晚上好。你现在连线的是哈罗德·华盛顿。
Good evening. Mr. Washington, could you clear up a point for me? I understand that once you move into city hall, you're going to remove all the elevator boxes and replace them with vines. Is that true?
晚上好。华盛顿先生，你能为我澄清一个问题吗？我听说一旦你进入市政厅，你打算拆除所有的电梯厢，换成藤蔓。这是真的吗？
What? Replace them with what?
什么？换成什么？
With vines.
藤蔓。
Vines, V-I-N-E-S?
藤蔓，V-I-N-E-S？
You know what?
你知道吗？
No, no.
不，不。
I'm not even going to ask you why. And--
我甚至不想问你为什么。而且——
No, I don't think we have 3 million Tarzans in this city.
不，我不认为我们城市里有300万个泰山。
Good evening. Randall is gone.
晚上好。兰德尔离开了。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. November 25 is the 10th anniversary of the death of Chicago's first Black mayor, Harold Washington. He died early in his second term of office. Today we remember his story and ask why the largest cities in the country-- New York, Los Angeles, Chicago-- no longer have Black mayors. Act One of our program is about the past. Act Two is about the present and the future.
来自WBEZ芝加哥和公共广播国际，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。11月25日是芝加哥首位黑人市长哈罗德·华盛顿逝世10周年纪念日。他在第二个任期初期就去世了。今天，我们回顾他的故事，并提出疑问：为什么这个国家最大的城市——纽约、洛杉矶、芝加哥——不再有黑人市长了？我们节目的第一幕关于过去，第二幕关于现在和未来。
A word about the voices you're going to be hearing over the course of this hour-- it's mostly people who were close to Harold Washington, many of them activists and politicians-- Lu Palmer, Judge Eugene Pincham, Congressman Danny Davis, then Alderman Eugene Sawyer. There are people from his administration, Jacky Grimshaw, Grayson Mitchell, Timuel Black, and some reporters who followed his story-- Vernon Jarrett, Monroe Anderson, Gary Rivlin, and Laura Washington, who later became his press secretary. There will also be an occasional opponent or voter. Stay with us.
关于这一小时你将听到的声音，多半是那些与哈罗德·华盛顿亲近的人，其中许多是活动家和政客——卢·帕尔默、尤金·平查姆法官、国会议员丹尼·戴维斯，还有当时的议员尤金·索耶。此外还有他政府的工作人员，杰基·格里姆肖、格雷森·米切尔、蒂缪尔·布莱克，以及一些追踪他故事的记者——弗农·贾雷特、门罗·安德森、加里·里夫林，还有后来成为他新闻秘书的劳拉·华盛顿。偶尔也会有反对者或选民的声音。请继续收听。
Act One, Yesterday. For decades, Chicago politics had been run with an iron hand by the legendary political boss, Richard J. Daley. Our story begins just after his death in 1976, when the machine was sputtering a bit with no strong leader and the possibility-- a small possibility-- of change. To give you a sense of what it meant to be a loyal Black alderman in the Chicago machine at that time, consider what happened in City Hall the day Richard Daley died.
第一幕，昨天。几十年来，芝加哥政治一直由传奇政治老板理查德·J·戴利铁腕掌控。我们的故事从他1976年去世后开始，当时机器因为没有强有力的领导人而有些运转不灵，出现了一丝——微小的——变革可能。为了让你了解当时作为芝加哥机器中一名忠诚的黑人议员意味着什么，看看理查德·戴利去世那天市政厅发生的事情。
By tradition, the president pro tem of the city council should at least occupy the mayor's office until such time as a process was determined for the election of a new mayor.
按照传统，市议会的临时议长至少应该占据市长办公室，直到确定新市长选举的程序为止。
And who was the--
那是谁——
That was Wilson Frost--
那是威尔逊·弗罗斯特——
Black alderman.
黑人议员。
--a loyal Black alderman from the 34th Ward, a Daley Democrat, a lawyer, impeccable reputation, impeccable credentials. The only mis-qualification he had was he's Black. God ordained that he be born Black. And the power structure sent police officers to the fifth floor, armed, to sit at the door to prevent Frost from even entering the mayor's office. That was a tremendous insult.
——一位来自第34选区的忠诚黑人议员，一位戴利民主党人，律师，声誉无可挑剔，资历无可挑剔。他唯一的“不合格”之处就是他是黑人。上帝注定他生为黑人。权力结构派武装警察到五楼，坐在门口，阻止弗罗斯特进入市长办公室。那是一种巨大的侮辱。
It was an insult, but it was not unusual. The white machine picked who the Black leaders would be. And mostly, those leaders did what they were told. Blacks in Chicago had nowhere to go but the Democratic machine. They were stuck. But then there were a series of famous and especially infuriating insults from the white political establishment. Biggest among them-- Black voters finally elected an anti-machine candidate named Jane Byrne, who, once in office, betrayed them, sucked up to the white machine, made appointments and decisions specifically to prove she was not in the pocket of Black Chicago.
这是一种侮辱，但也并不罕见。白人机器挑选谁可以成为黑人领导人。而且多数情况下，那些领导人对指令言听计从。芝加哥的黑人除了加入民主党机器别无去处。他们被困住了。但随后发生了一系列来自白人政治建制派的著名且特别令人愤怒的侮辱。其中最严重的是——黑人选民最终选出了一位名为简·伯恩的反机器候选人，她一上任就背叛了他们，向白人机器献媚，所作的任命和决定专门为了证明她不是芝加哥黑人的傀儡。
Then circumstances came together-- some by planning, some by luck-- that made it possible to elect a Black mayor. The planning-- organizers registered over 100,000 minority voters, held rallies and meetings, declaring it was time to elect a Black mayor. The luck-- two white candidates split the white vote. One more piece of luck-- the Chicago Democratic Party had created, in spite of itself, Harold Washington. Vernon Jarrett was an old friend and a local newspaper columnist.
后来，各种情况汇聚在一起——有些是计划好的，有些是运气使然——使得选举一位黑人市长成为可能。计划方面——组织者注册了超过10万名少数族裔选民，举行集会和会议，宣布是时候选出一位黑人市长了。运气方面——两名白人候选人分散了白人选票。又多了一份运气——芝加哥民主党在不知不觉中培养出了哈罗德·华盛顿。弗农·贾雷特是一位老朋友，也是当地报纸的专栏作家。
And Harold was in that party now. Don't forget, Harold had been a precinct captain. His father had groomed him as a precinct captain since he was-- what-- 11 years old. But his father was done wrong. So Harold is an unusual person in that he nursed this resentment of how the Democratic Party had deserted his father at one time, when his father ran for alderman of the 3rd Ward.
哈罗德当时就在那个党里。别忘了，哈罗德曾是一名选区队长。他父亲在他——大约——11岁时就开始培养他做选区队长。但他父亲受到了不公正的待遇。所以哈罗德是一个不寻常的人，他怀着一种怨恨，因为民主党曾在他父亲竞选第三选区议员时抛弃了他。
He was a confused guy, got a little sense of mission in him and wanting to do the right thing. But yet, he was balanced off by this pragmatism that you got to play ball, to a degree, with the organization. And he was correct. He wouldn't have made it without the Democratic machine.
他是个充满困惑的人，心中有一种使命感，想做正确的事。但他又被这种实用主义所平衡，即在某种程度上，你必须与组织合作。他是对的。没有民主党机器，他是不可能成功的。
Usually, in Chicago, political activists had a choice. They could go with politicians who were good on the issues but then had no political experience dealing with the machine, or they could get hacks, who knew the machine but were terrible in the issues. Washington was the rarest kind of politician-- delivered on the issues, knew the machine-- which was why, in fact, he did not want the job. Lu Palmer was at the center of the effort to draft a Black mayor.
通常在芝加哥，政治活动家有两种选择。他们要么选择在议题上表现出色但缺乏与机器打交道的政治经验的政客，要么选择了解机器但在议题上表现糟糕的政客。华盛顿是最稀有的那种政客——既能解决议题，又了解机器——这事实上也是他最初不想干这份工作的原因。卢·帕尔默是推动选举黑人市长努力的核心人物。
Well, we talked to Harold. He was reluctant, very reluctant. At the time, he was in Congress and was enjoying being a congressman.
嗯，我们和哈罗德谈过。他很勉强，非常勉强。当时他在国会，很享受做国会议员的日子。
Enjoying it partly because he was far from the machine.
享受它，部分是因为他远离了机器。
He set some requirements, how much money we'd have to raise. We'd have to get 50,000 new voters.
他设定了一些要求，比如我们需要筹集多少钱。我们必须获得5万名新选民。
He asked that, thinking, well, you'll never get that or--
他提出那个要求，心想，好吧，你们永远做不到，或者——
He used 50,000 knowing that no way in the world are they going to come up with 50,000 new-- and that was hard in those days, to come up with 50,000 registered voters.
他用了“5万”这个数字，知道世界上根本不可能凑齐5万名新——而且在那个年代，要凑齐5万名注册选民是很困难的。
They registered 130,000 new voters.
他们注册了13万名新选民。
May I jump ahead a moment? You know what put Harold Washington over with the broad masses of Black people was when they had the primary debates.
我可以跳过一个瞬间吗？你知道是什么让哈罗德·华盛顿赢得了广大黑人群众的心吗？是初选辩论的时候。
Oh, the triumph was the televised debate.
哦，那场电视辩论是巨大的胜利。
Because you had Daley. You had Byrne. And then you had somebody who could talk-- Harold.
因为有戴利。有伯恩。然后有一个真正能说会道的人——哈罗德。
Let's review that lineup. Daley was Richard M. Daley, son of the late mayor, Richard J. Daley. He is, by the way, our current mayor here in Chicago. Byrne was Jane Byrne, the then-incumbent mayor. And Harold-- you already know Harold. Those were the three Democratic contenders in the mayoral race. It is the fall of 1983. Here's a typical exchange between them. The three of them were asked at one point what they would do, if anything, about the police department's Office of Professional Standards, the place in the police department which handles complaints about police misconduct and brutality.
让我们回顾一下那场阵容。戴利是理查德·M·戴利，已故市长理查德·J·戴利的儿子。顺便说一下，他正是我们芝加哥现任市长。伯恩是简·伯恩，当时的在任市长。而哈罗德——你已经认识哈罗德了。他们是市长竞选中的三位民主党竞争者。那是1983年秋天。这里有一个他们之间的典型交流。有人曾问他们三人，对于警察局的专业标准办公室——负责处理有关警察不当行为和暴行的投诉的警察局内设机构——他们会采取什么行动。
Jane Byrne and Richard Daley sound basically like normal politicians. They offer dull truisms like--
简·伯恩和理查德·戴利听起来基本上就像普通的政客。他们说着枯燥的陈词滥调，比如——
I believe that the members of the police board, chaired by Reverend Wilbur Daniels, really do take that job very seriously. And I--
我相信，由威尔伯·丹尼尔斯牧师主持的警察委员会成员，确实非常严肃地对待这份工作。而且我——
Here is the most specific that Richard Daley, then state's attorney, got that day.
这是时任州检察长的理查德·戴利那天所能说出的最具体的内容。
I think, like anything else, there must be improvement. And there is nothing wrong with improvement in the Office of Professional Standards.
我认为，像其他任何事情一样，必须有改进。专业标准办公室的改进没有任何问题。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
When Harold Washington comes on, what is most noticeable is that he sounds like a human being.
当哈罗德·华盛顿发言时，最引人注目的是他听起来像个活生生的人。
The side's question is, what would I do to improve the Office of Professional Standards? When I answer it, I'll be the only one who answered the question.
对方的问题是，我会采取什么措施来改善专业标准办公室？当我回答这个问题时，我将是唯一一个真正回答了问题的人。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
The Office of Professional Standards was arrived at after a long and tortuous situation in this city in which members-- not all, but members-- of the Chicago Police Department consistently refused to be adequate and professional in their handling of Hispanic, Black people. It's just that simple. It's a long-standing--
专业标准办公室的设立，是在这个城市经历了一段长期且痛苦的情况之后，其中芝加哥警察局的成员——并非全部，但确实有成员——始终拒绝在处理西班牙裔、黑人问题时表现得适度且专业。事情就这么简单。这是一个长期存在的——
What happened was, he became plausible to the Black community. Suddenly, they heard somebody who was articulate, knew what he was talking about, and was forceful.
结果是，他让黑人社区觉得他是可以信任的。突然间，他们听到了一位口齿伶俐、知道自己在说什么、且强有力的人。
In the first place, the appointees, all but nine, are political appointees. Many of the investigators are wedded to or related to police members of the Chicago Police Department.
首先，这些任命人员中，除了九个以外，全是政治任命。许多调查员与芝加哥警察局的警察成员有裙带关系或亲属关系。
A lot of people, Black people, had felt all along that we've been bossed by dunderheads. They are not that bright. They don't know that much. And Harold, Harold Washington, standing there between Jane Byrne and Richard M. Daley, the son, so cool, so well read that people, Black people, were just thrilled. It was like watching Michael Jordan with a basketball.
很多黑人一直觉得我们被一群傻瓜领导着。他们没那么聪明。他们懂得不多。而哈罗德，哈罗德·华盛顿，站在简·伯恩和理查德·M·戴利（儿子）之间，那么冷静，那么博学，以至于黑人们感到非常振奋。那就像看着迈克尔·乔丹打篮球。
Mr. Brzeczek, unfortunately, at the behest of this mayor, as a minion of this mayor, as a subaltern of this mayor, as a subordinate of this mayor, has destroyed his credibility--
布泽切克先生，不幸的是，在这个市长的授意下，作为这个市长的走狗，作为这个市长的下属，作为这个市长的部下，已经摧毁了他的信誉——
Harold used to use words that even some of these journalists, these white journalists, had to scratch their head and go to the dictionary. Black people loved that.
哈罗德总是用一些词汇，即使是那些白人记者，也得抓耳挠腮去查字典。黑人们喜欢这一点。
And he jumped on Jane Byrne and took her by surprise, shocked her. And she was still reeling from the shock. And I shall never forget it, that night. I said, this man's got it made. He's in.
他猛击简·伯恩，让她措手不及，震惊了她。而她那天晚上还沉浸在震惊中。我永远不会忘记那一晚。我说，这家伙成了。他赢定了。
Here's one way that being a Black candidate for office is different from being a white candidate. If you're Black, you get thrown into the chasm of misunderstanding that divides white America for Black America, in a way that white politicians almost never are. Two Americas simply see certain things differently. For instance, what should Harold Washington say about the late mayor, Richard J. Daley? Many white Chicagoans still held him in awe, while Black and Latino Chicago, for good reasons, had a different take. Well, here's what Harold decided to say.
这里有一种黑人候选人与白人候选人不同的方式。如果你是黑人，你会被扔进分裂美国白人与黑人的误解深渊，这是白人政客几乎从未经历过的。两个美国以不同的方式看待某些事情。例如，哈罗德·华盛顿应该如何评价已故市长理查德·J·戴利？许多芝加哥白人仍然对他怀有敬畏之心，而芝加哥的黑人和拉丁裔，出于正当理由，则有不同的看法。嗯，这是哈罗德决定说的话。
When he says that he would hope that I would have all the good qualities of past mayors, there are no good qualities of past mayors to be had-- none, none, none.
当他说希望我具备过去市长所有的优点时，过去的市长根本没有任何优点可言——一个都没有，一个都没有，一个都没有。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
None. I did not mourn at the bar of the late mayor. I regret anyone dying. I have no regrets about him leaving. He was a racist from the core, head to toe and hip to hip. There's no dangerous doubt about it. And he spewed and fought and oppressed Black people to the point that some of them thought that was the way they were supposed to live, just like some slaves on the plantation thought that was the way they were supposed to live.
没有。我没有在那位已故市长的灵柩前哀悼。我为任何人的离世感到遗憾。我对他离世没有任何遗憾。他从骨子里、从头到脚、从里到外都是个种族主义者。这一点毫无疑问。他喷吐着毒液，战斗并压迫黑人，以至于他们中的一些人认为那就是他们应该有的生活方式，就像种植园里的一些奴隶认为那也是他们应有的生活方式一样。
It was just like everything else he did and said. It was historic. And no one would challenge the late mayor on anything, much less call him that kind of name. And I think that was what made him so provocative. It's what made him so loved by the people who supported him and so hated by the people who wanted to deny him the office. He didn't mince any words.
就像他所做和所说的一切一样。那是历史性的。没有人会挑战已故市长的任何事情，更不用说叫他那种名字了。我认为这正是他如此激进的原因。这正是他受到支持者如此爱戴，又受到那些想剥夺他职位的人如此仇恨的原因。他说话从不拐弯抹角。
I'd give no hosannas to a racist, nor do I appreciate or respect his son. If his name were anything other than Daley, his campaign would be a joke. He has nothing to offer anybody but a bent-up, tin-can smile, no background.
我对一个种族主义者不会给任何赞美，我也不欣赏或尊重他的儿子。如果他不叫戴利，他的竞选就是个笑话。除了一个扭曲的、罐头般的微笑，他没有任何背景，也没有什么可以提供给任何人。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And he runs on the legacy of his name, an insult to common sense and decency. Everything I've ever got in the world, I work for it. Nobody gave me anything.
他靠着自己姓氏的遗产竞选，这是对常识和礼仪的侮辱。我一生中得到的一切，都是我通过努力挣来的。没有人给我任何东西。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The primary taught him that he could transcend being the third candidate, of being the Black candidate. And he could take that Adam Powell positioning. He could take that Marcus Garvey positioning, where you're a hybrid between the politician and the public man. And you become somewhere between Muhammad Ali, Michael Jackson, somewhere in superstar.
初选教会了他，他可以超越“第三候选人”或“黑人候选人”的身份。他可以采用亚当·鲍威尔那样的定位。他可以采用马库斯·加维那样的定位，成为政客和公众人物之间的混合体。你变得介于穆罕默德·阿里和迈克尔·杰克逊之间，某种巨星。
And although I may sound abrasive, I have no malice toward anybody. I have a job to do. I've got place to go and things to do. And I approach this job just like any masterful surgeon when you have to cut out a cancer. I cut it out with no emotion. Get it out. Get it out.
虽然我听起来可能有点刺耳，但我对任何人都没有恶意。我有一份工作要做。我有地方要去，有事情要做。我对待这份工作就像任何杰出的外科医生在必须切除癌症时一样。我毫无情绪地切除它。把它切掉。把它切掉。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
This dominant culture may have messed up my pocket, but they haven't messed up my head one bit. I believe in the powers of redemption. And I simply cannot believe in the God I worship, that He would permit us to sit on this Earth for 400 years-- or, rather, in this country for 400 years-- and suffer the indignities which we have suffered, piled time after time, higher after higher, and so heavy, it has almost broken the backs of one of the most powerful people in this world. I can't believe there is no redemption.
这种主流文化可能搞乱了我的口袋，但它们一点也没搞乱我的头脑。我相信救赎的力量。我根本无法相信我崇拜的上帝，祂会允许我们在这地球上坐等400年——或者更确切地说，在这国家呆了400年——遭受我们所受过的羞辱，一次又一次地堆积，越来越高，重到几乎压垮了这个世界上最强大的民族之一。我不相信没有救赎。
But that redemption is not going to come out in hatred. It's going to come out in positive attitude toward our fellow man. We've come into the 1980s with an understanding that we have not just a right but a responsibility to give the best that we have to a society. We want to give it. And we're going to give it if we have to beat them across the head, knock them down, and make them take it. We're going to give it to them.
但那种救赎不会来自仇恨。它将来自于对我们同胞的积极态度。我们进入了1980年代，意识到我们不仅有权利，更有责任为社会贡献我们最好的东西。我们想贡献它。如果必须打他们的头，把他们打倒，让他们接受，我们也要贡献给他们。我们要把它给他们。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
During this election and during Harold Washington's terms as mayor, in Chicago, every day was the day after the OJ verdict. Every day was a day when Black and white Chicago took a look at the same set of facts and drew two different conclusions. For instance, when the media raised questions about Washington's past, it made white Chicagoans question his qualifications for office, but it made minority voters more loyal.
在那次选举期间以及哈罗德·华盛顿担任市长期间，在芝加哥，每一天都是“辛普森案判决”后的日子。每一天，黑人与白人芝加哥都在看着同一组事实，却得出两种截然不同的结论。例如，当媒体对华盛顿的过去提出质疑时，这让白人芝加哥人质疑他的任职资格，但却让少数族裔选民更加忠诚。
In 1983, when Harold announced his candidacy, 95% of Black people never heard of him. And what happened was, the white power structure media first criticized Harold for having been convicted of a tax violation. He failed to file his returns.
1983年，哈罗德宣布参选时，95%的黑人从未听说过他。结果是，白人权力结构的媒体首先批评哈罗德曾因违反税务规定被定罪。他没有申报退税。
We should be precise about this. It wasn't that he hadn't paid. It's that he hadn't filed the return.
我们应该精确一点。不是他没交税，而是他没有申报退税。
He hadn't filed a return. That's right. He paid withholding. There was nothing to it. So what difference does it make? But the point is, when this occurred, it gave him publicity that he otherwise would not have gotten. Many people in the Black community resented the criticism being leveled against him.
他没有申报退税。没错。他预扣税款了。这根本没什么大不了的。那又有什么区别呢？但重点是，当这种情况发生时，它给了他本不会得到的宣传。黑人社区的许多人对他受到的批评感到愤慨。
They then said, well, you're not married. You can't be mayor if you're not married. We made Jane Byrne married McMullen. We made Jim Thompson married Jane Thompson. We made Kennedy, in the Senate, go back to his wife. You cannot be a viable politician if you're not married.
他们接着说，好吧，你还没结婚。如果你没结婚，你就不能当市长。我们让简·伯恩嫁给了麦克马伦。我们让吉姆·汤普森娶了简·汤普森。我们让参议院的肯尼迪回到他妻子身边。如果你没结婚，你就不是一个合格的政客。
Here, again, he did something that Blacks aren't accustomed to seeing Blacks do. He stood up. And he said, I'm not going to get married. Everybody thought, man, go marry if this is going to make-- and he said, I'm not. Nobody can tell me to marry. I don't want to marry. My marital status has nothing to do with my qualifications as mayor.
在这里，他又做了一件黑人还没习惯看到黑人做的事。他站了起来。他说，我不会结婚。每个人都想，伙计，如果这能成事就去结婚吧——但他却说，我不结。没有人能强迫我结婚。我不想结婚。我的婚姻状况与我作为市长的资格无关。
And here, again, the Black community looked at him with a great deal more respect now. Because many of the people, Black folks, said mayor don't want to be married no way. So they said, go on, Harold.
而在这里，黑人社区现在以更多的尊重看着他。因为许多人，黑人老百姓说，市长反正也不想结婚。所以他们说，继续吧，哈罗德。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But he got some more publicity. And quite frankly, you will have to concede-- I certainly will say it-- that had a white candidate with the same baggage been running, there's no way in the world he would have been elected mayor.
但他获得了更多宣传。老实说，你必须承认——我肯定会说——如果是一个有同样包袱的白人候选人参选，他绝对不可能当选市长。
How do you figure that?
你怎么看出来的？
Well, it's true. Your white candidate who'd been in jail for failing to file a tax return, who wasn't married, rumored to be homosexual-- everybody knew Harold wasn't a homosexual, but that was the rumor they tried to create-- and a disbarred lawyer? No way in the world, if he was white, would he be elected.
嗯，这是事实。你的白人候选人，坐过牢是因为没申报退税，没结婚，传言是同性恋——每个人都知道哈罗德不是同性恋，但那是他们试图制造的谣言——还是个被吊销执照的律师？绝不可能，如果他是白人，他根本不会当选。
And what should we think of that?
我们该怎么看这一点呢？
What I think of it? I think it's here again-- well, if South Africa can elect a man who's a felon--
我的想法？我认为还是那回事——如果南非能选出一个重罪犯——
Nelson Mandela.
纳尔逊·曼德拉。
Nelson Mandela, 27 years.
纳尔逊·曼德拉，27年。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know what's interesting about it-- is that none of those criticisms also go to what the white fear was. I wonder, as far as you could tell, what was at the heart of the white fear?
有趣的是——这些批评都没有触及白人恐惧的核心。我想知道，据你所知，白人恐惧的核心是什么？
Because he's Black.
因为他是黑人。
And so the two Chicagos headed to primary day, white Chicago mostly ignoring the Washington candidacy, Black Chicago abuzz about it. And when he won, the two Chicagos had wildly different reactions, as you might expect. Monroe Anderson was a reporter at The Chicago Tribune at the time. He was one of the few Blacks who worked in the newsroom the day after Harold Washington's primary victory.
于是两个芝加哥走向了初选日，白人芝加哥大多无视华盛顿的参选，而黑人芝加哥则对此议论纷纷。当他获胜时，两个芝加哥有着正如你所料的截然不同的反应。门罗·安德森当时是《芝加哥论坛报》的记者。哈罗德·华盛顿初选获胜后的第二天，他是新闻编辑室里为数不多的黑人之一。
There was such a somber feeling around that place. It was like somebody's family member, beloved family member, had died or something. It was just really somber. And we were in this jubilant mood, except you did not feel comfortable expressing it, looking it.
那个地方有一种沉闷的感觉。就像某个人的家人，心爱的家人去世了一样。真的非常压抑。我们当时处于欢庆的心情中，只是你不会感到舒服去表达它，表现出来。
So we walked around, (SINGING) doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo. (SPEAKING) And then we would go into somebody's office or someplace aside and go, yes, and jump up and down and then come out and walk around. Oh, yes. We're reporters too. Yes, we understand. [LAUGHS]
所以我们走来走去，（哼唱）嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。（说话）然后我们会走进某个人的办公室或某个隐蔽的地方，说“耶”，然后跳上跳下，再出来走来走去。哦，是的。我们也是记者。是的，我们理解。[笑声]
After primary day, things got ugly. Usually, winning the Democratic primary for mayor in Chicago means you've won the office. The Republican Party doesn't count in city elections. But in this case, as Chicago moved toward the general election in April 1983, 90% of white Chicago deserted the Democratic Party to vote for a Republican named Bernie Epton. One of his campaign slogans-- "Epton, before it's too late."
初选日之后，事情变得丑陋起来。通常，在芝加哥赢得市长民主党初选就意味着你赢得了这个职位。共和党人在城市选举中并不算什么。但在这种情况下，随着芝加哥向1983年4月的大选迈进，90%的芝加哥白人抛弃了民主党，投票给了一位名叫伯尼·埃普顿的共和党人。他的一句竞选口号是——“埃普顿，趁现在还来得及。”
Black Chicago saw the Democratic defections as racism, pure and simple. Meanwhile, white policemen circulated hate literature illustrated with chicken bones and watermelons. And in perhaps the most famous incident in the campaign, while stumping with Walter Mondale, Harold Washington stopped at St. Pascal's church on the city's white northwest side.
芝加哥黑人将民主党人的倒戈视为种族主义，纯粹的种族主义。与此同时，白人警察散发带有炸鸡骨头和西瓜图案的仇恨宣传品。在竞选期间最著名的一次事件中，哈罗德·华盛顿在与沃尔特·蒙代尔一起拉票时，在城市西北区的圣帕斯卡教堂前停了下来。
It was almost a riot.
几乎要发生骚乱。
Monroe Anderson covered it for the Tribune.
门罗·安德森为《论坛报》报道了这件事。
When Harold showed up and the press entourage showed up, there was this angry-- people were, like, approaching the car. People were out of control. I thought that we were in physical danger. And then we get to the church, and somebody spray painted on the church graffiti that said, "Die, nigger, die."
当哈罗德出现，媒体随从人员出现时，那里有一群愤怒的——人们，就像，向车子走过来。人们失控了。我以为我们处于身体危险之中。然后我们到了教堂，有人在教堂喷涂了涂鸦，上面写着：“死吧，黑鬼，去死吧。”
On a Catholic Church?
在天主教堂上？
Yes.
是的。
Meanwhile, something curious happened. Occasionally, Harold Washington or one of his supporters would say, in passing, something like, it's our turn now. And when they did, it made headlines. White Chicago and the mainstream press saw it as more than just ethnic pride. It was seen as threatening. This is one of the ways that being a Black politician in America is different than being a Polish politician or an Irish politician. Judge Pincham.
与此同时，发生了一件奇怪的事情。偶尔，哈罗德·华盛顿或他的支持者会顺口说一些类似“现在轮到我们了”的话。而当他们这么说时，就会登上头条。芝加哥白人和主流媒体认为这不仅仅是族群自豪感。这被视为一种威胁。这是在美国作为黑人政客与作为波兰或爱尔兰政客不同的方式之一。平查姆法官。
The difference is very, very simple. And that is, when the Polish attempt to get a Polish mayor, it's good ethnic politics. When the Irish try to get an Irish mayor, it's good ethnic politics. But when the Blacks try to get a Black mayor, it's racism.
区别很简单，非常简单。那就是，当波兰人试图拥有一位波兰市长时，那是良好的族群政治。当爱尔兰人试图拥有一位爱尔兰市长时，那是良好的族群政治。但当黑人试图拥有一位黑人市长时，那就是种族主义。
Glenn Leonard grew up in the white southwest side of Chicago, didn't vote for Harold Washington.
格伦·伦纳德在芝加哥西南区的白人社区长大，没有投票给哈罗德·华盛顿。
I think a lot of people thought that he was going to bring in a lot of people that were going to be Black and were going to change the city. Now we have our chance. Now let's go ahead and do it. Let's right all these so-called wrongs. Whether they were right or wrong, it's another story. Let's right these wrongs. Let's move in. Let's take over. Let's have more of a say in the local government. And people just saw that as a threat. They thought, well, these people are going to come in, move into the corner house or whatever, and another white flight starts again. I think that that was a big fear.
我想很多人认为他会带来很多黑人，会改变这个城市。现在我们有机会了。现在让我们去做吧。让我们纠正所有这些所谓的错误。无论是对是错，那是另一回事。让我们纠正这些错误。让我们搬进来。让我们接管它。让我们在地方政府中拥有更多的话语权。人们只是把这看作一种威胁。他们想，好吧，这些人要来了，搬进拐角的房子什么的，白人逃离又开始了。我认为这是一种巨大的恐惧。
Chicago will become another Detroit, people said, another Cleveland. Property values would fall, businesses leave. Many whites had already fled one set of neighborhoods during white flight. And Glenn says that white Chicago was used to having the late Mayor Daley protect their neighborhoods, for instance, by blocking federal schemes to bring in low-income public housing all over the city. But Harold Washington wouldn't do that.
人们说，芝加哥会变成另一个底特律，另一个克利夫兰。房产价值会下跌，企业会离开。许多白人在白人逃离期间已经逃离过一次社区了。格伦说，芝加哥白人习惯于让已故市长戴利保护他们的社区，例如，阻止联邦政府将低收入公共住房带到全市各地的计划。但哈罗德·华盛顿不会那样做。
He was going to, obviously, no longer block these. And these low-income housing units would come into every neighborhood in the city or whatever. And that would start the ball rolling in your-- what do they call it in the Far East when the communists-- the domino effect. Thank you. [LAUGHS]
他显然不会再阻止这些了。这些低收入住房单元会进入城市的每个社区什么的。那会在你的——远东地区当共产主义者时叫什么——多米诺骨牌效应。谢谢。[笑声]
This is one thing that Black politicians have to deal with that white politicians don't. And this is true from Chicago to Washington, DC, from North Carolina to South Africa. They have to deal with white fear. Harold Washington.
这是黑人政客必须处理而白人政客不需要的一件事。这从芝加哥到华盛顿特区，从北卡罗来纳到南非，都是真实的。他们必须处理白人的恐惧。哈罗德·华盛顿。
We have 670,000 Black registered voters in this city. When you get right down to it, the votes are here. They're here. They're here. And every group-- and I've said it before, and I'll say it again. And the press takes it and runs out in left field with it. Every group that gets our percentage of the population, they don't go around begging. They don't go around explaining. They don't have any excuses to make. They just move on in and take one of their own and put them in office. That's what we should do. That's what democracy is all about.
我们在这个城市有67万名注册的黑人选民。当你真正深入了解时，选票就在这里。它们在这里。它们在这里。每个群体——我之前说过，我还要再说一遍。媒体对此大做文章。每个占我们人口比例的群体，他们不会到处乞求。他们不会到处解释。他们不需要找任何借口。他们只是搬进去，带上自己的人，让他们担任公职。这就是我们应该做的。这就是民主的意义所在。
Problem is, when your opponents don't see your election, it's just the normal workings of democracy. How Harold Washington tried to rise above their fear after he squeaked out a narrow victory in the general election and took office, that's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
问题是，当你的对手不把你的选举看作民主的正常运作时。哈罗德·华盛顿在他赢得大选并上任后，如何试图超越这种恐惧，我们将在一分钟后，从公共广播国际，节目继续时为您介绍。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. But today, we're breaking from our usual format to bring you this parable about race and politics in America, the story of Harold Washington, Chicago's first Black mayor, who entered office in 1983 and died just four years later, just a few months into his second term. November 25 is the 10th anniversary of his death.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。通常每周我们都会选择一个主题，带给您各种关于该主题的不同故事。但今天，我们要打破常规，为您讲述这个关于美国种族与政治的寓言，芝加哥首位黑人市长哈罗德·华盛顿的故事，他于1983年上任，四年后便去世了，离他的第二个任期仅几个月。11月25日是他逝世10周年纪念日。
So in Chicago and in most American big cities, the way it used to work-- and I say used to with some reservations. In Chicago, you could argue that it still works this way. The way it used to work was that when Irish-Americans took the mayor's office, or Italian-Americans, or Polish-Americans, they channeled contracts and patronage jobs and other municipal goodies to their own communities. Lu Palmer was one of the people at the center of the movement to elect a Black mayor in Chicago. He convened the early organizational meetings in his basement. It is hard to imagine that Harold Washington would have ever come to office without him. And he was disappointed by Harold.
那么，在芝加哥和大多数美国大城市，过去运作的方式——我用“过去”这个词有所保留。在芝加哥，你可能会争辩说它仍然是这样运作的。过去运作的方式是，当美国爱尔兰人占据市长职位，或者美国意大利人、美国波兰人时，他们会向自己的社区输送合同、赞助职位和各种市政好处。卢·帕尔默是推动选举芝加哥黑人市长运动的核心人物之一。他在自家地下室召集了早期的组织会议。很难想象如果没有他，哈罗德·华盛顿会入主市政厅。他却对哈罗德感到失望。
I don't know. But he never became what I would consider the Black mayor. Black people wanted something that was so simple-- fairness. And I used to get upset with Harold after he became elected, because Harold was too fair. In fact, he would say in his speeches, I'm going to be fair. I'm going to be more than fair.
我不知道。但他从未成为我所认为的“黑人市长”。黑人想要的东西很简单——公平。我常在哈罗德当选后因为他而感到沮丧，因为哈罗德太公平了。事实上，他在演讲中会说，我要公平。我要比公平更公平。
No one, but no one in this city, no matter where they live or how they live, is free from the fairness of our administration. We'll find you and be fair to you wherever you are.
这座城市里没有任何人，无论他们住在哪里或如何生活，都不受我们行政公平的影响。我们会找到你，并对你公平，无论你在哪里。
And I used to cringe--
我常感到畏缩——
But I need your help.
但我需要你们的帮助。
--when he would say, I'm not only going to be fair, but I'm going to be fairer than fair. Well, come on. You don't have to go overboard. And Harold did.
——当他说，我不但要公平，还要“比公平更公平”。好吧，别这样。你不需要走极端。但哈罗德做了。
Those of us who are considered radicals, we simply believe that since the Daleys, Byrne, and all the rest of the white mayors had always put white people first, with any question, without any apology, we said that Harold got to put Black people first. And that's what we wanted.
我们这些被认为是激进派的人，只是相信既然戴利、伯恩以及所有其他白人市长总是把白人放在第一位，毫无疑问，没有任何道歉，我们就说哈罗德必须把黑人放在第一位。这就是我们想要的。
I'm not sure we wanted to be to white people what Daley was to Black people. That is, he was just ridiculous. And the present Daley-- same way. But people, they wanted to see the opportunity to have our community thrive like other communities.
我不确定我们是否想成为对待白人就像戴利对待黑人那样。也就是说，他是荒谬的。现在的戴利——也是一样。但人们，他们想看到我们的社区像其他社区一样繁荣的机会。
It wasn't just Black nationalists like Lu Palmer who felt this way. Old-time machine loyalists, like Eugene Sawyer, who was the Black alderman that the white Democratic machine wanted to succeed Harold Washington as mayor, said the same thing.
不只是像卢·帕尔默那样的黑人民族主义者有这种感觉。老一辈的机器忠诚派，比如尤金·索耶，那位白人民主党机器想要接替哈罗德·华盛顿担任市长的黑人议员，也说了同样的话。
And that was part of the things, that I think we probably were too fair. I think Harold was too fair.
那是其中的一部分，我认为我们可能太公平了。我认为哈罗德太公平了。
In what way?
在什么方面？
A lot of people think he was too fair, by giving a lot more and giving everybody the same thing. And people didn't expect it. A lot of Black folks think that you should have given your own people a little bit more.
很多人认为他太公平了，给予了太多，给了每个人同样的东西。人们没有预料到。很多黑人认为你应该为你自己的人民多给一点。
Well, a major problem with being a Black person in America--
嗯，在美国作为一个黑人的主要问题——
Reporter Monroe Anderson.
记者门罗·安德森。
--is you're in this trap. Because-- and this is sort of our curse and our blessing because of this racial history, is that we have been complaining and pointing out all these inequities for a very long time. And therefore, all these things that you have pointed out that have been an injustice to you, now that you're in power, you can't do because it'll be injustice to whites. And therefore, the rules have to be this great, even, everything's fair and square.
——就是你陷入了这个陷阱。因为——这也是我们因为这种种族历史而受到的诅咒和祝福，那就是我们很长一段时间以来一直在抱怨并指出所有这些不平等。因此，所有这些你指出的对你不公的事情，现在你掌权了，你却不能做，因为那会对白人不公。因此，规则必须是这种伟大的、平等的、一切都是公平公正的。
People close to Harold Washington say that it was smart politics for him to be fairer than fairer. After all, Black wards had been treated so unfairly in the past that simply giving them the same services that the rest of the city got would be a huge step forward. It was also the political stance he felt most comfortable with by disposition. And when Black politicians or community activists came to City Hall, trying to get more for one neighborhood over another, he was so enormously popular in Black Chicago, where 85% of the Black electorate turned out to vote for him, and where everyone simply referred to him as Harold, that he could ignore the pressure. Jacky Grimshaw was a staff person.
哈罗德·华盛顿身边的人说，他表现得“比公平更公平”是明智的政治。毕竟，黑人选区过去受到过太多的不公平待遇，只需给他们提供与城市其他地区相同的服务，就已经是巨大的进步。这也是他从性格上感到最舒服的政治立场。当黑人政客或社区活动家来到市政厅，试图为一个街区争取比另一个街区更多的利益时，他在芝加哥黑人社区非常受欢迎，那里85%的黑人选民出来为他投票，大家只称他为“哈罗德”，所以他可以无视这种压力。杰基·格里姆肖是他的工作人员。
I think there is a difference between the Black population and the Black politicians. I think, on the part of the Black politicians, it was definitely, it's our turn. And I had to deal with some of these folks. They'd come in, and they want 10 jobs and crap like that. Hey, there ain't 10 jobs. But I think on the part of the people, they were into fairness. I think the fairness thing played with them. They were proud of Harold. They supported him, what he was doing.
我认为黑人人口和黑人政客之间存在差异。我认为，就黑人政客而言，绝对是“轮到我们了”。我必须应付他们中的一些人。他们走进来，想要10个职位之类的。嘿，根本没有10个职位。但我认为就人民而言，他们追求的是公平。我认为公平的东西对他们有效。他们为哈罗德感到自豪。他们支持他，支持他所做的一切。
Privately, Harold Washington talked about the danger of doing away with the old patronage system, how it could make the first Black mayor weaker than any of his white predecessors. But publicly, for all intents and purposes, patronage was over.
私下里，哈罗德·华盛顿谈到了废除旧的赞助制度的危险，以及它如何使第一位黑人市长比他任何白人前任都更弱。但从公开角度看，赞助制度实际上已经结束了。
It's gone. It's gone. In the words of Cornell Davis, they said he wasn't dead. So I went to his grave, and I walked around that grave. And I stomped on that grave. And I jumped up and down. And I called out, patronage, patronage, are you alive? And patronage didn't answer. It is dead, dead, dead.
它没了。它没了。用科内尔·戴维斯的话说，他们说他没死。所以我去了他的墓地，我在坟墓上走来走去。我在那坟墓上踩了几脚。我跳上跳下。我大喊，赞助，赞助，你还活着吗？赞助没有回答。它死了，死了，死了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Washington attacked the machine. The machine struck back. From the first day of Washington's first city council meeting, 29 aldermen, all of them white, the old Democratic machine, teamed up to oppose him. For the first time in memory, a Chicago mayor did not control City Hall. It was the machine's 29 votes to Howard's 21 votes. The 29 not only blocked his appointments, it never brought them up for consideration. They blocked most of his legislative initiatives and dedicated enormous energy to looking for ways to embarrass him and thwart him.
华盛顿攻击了机器。机器进行了反击。从华盛顿第一次市议会会议的第一天起，29名议员，全是白人，即老民主党机器，联手反对他。记忆中第一次，芝加哥市长无法控制市政厅。那是机器的29票对华盛顿的21票。那29人不仅阻止了他的任命，甚至从未将它们提交审议。他们阻止了他大部分的立法倡议，并投入巨大精力寻找羞辱和阻挠他的方法。
It was mayhem, a battle so divisive and chaotic that for years, it sustained the disturbing animosity and suspicion between Black Chicago and white Chicago. Everyone took sides. It came to be known locally as Council Wars, after a local African-American comic named Aaron Freeman began staging moments in local politics as scenes from the Star Wars trilogy.
那是一场混乱，一场如此分裂和混乱的战斗，以至于多年来，它维持了芝加哥黑人与白人之间令人不安的敌意和猜疑。每个人都选边站。它在当地被称为“议会战争”，这是在一位名叫亚伦·弗里曼的当地非裔美国喜剧演员开始将当地政治中的时刻表演为《星球大战》三部曲场景之后。
Harold Washington appeared as Luke Skytalker, leader of the rebellion. Harold's main political opponent, Ed Vrdolyak, the alderman who led the 29, also got a big part.
哈罗德·华盛顿作为抵抗运动的领导者“卢克·天行者”出现。哈罗德的主要政治对手，领导那29人的议员埃德·弗多利亚克，也扮演了一个重要角色。
What are you doing in my office, Lord Darth Vrdolyak?
你在我的办公室里干什么，达斯·弗多利亚克勋爵？
[LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING]
[沉重的呼吸声]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I wish to discuss committee assignments for the new council. [LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING]
我想讨论新议会的委员会分配。[沉重的呼吸声]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I don't have to talk to you. I'm the mayor. I can do whatever I want. I can-- [STRAINED YELL]
我不必和你说话。我是市长。我可以做我想做的任何事。我可以——[吃力的喊叫]
[LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING]
[沉重的呼吸声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I find your lack of respect disturbing. It is obvious you do not know the power of the clout. It has served all of the mayors before you. It can bring you great wealth and power, or it can destroy you as easily. The choice is yours.
我发现你缺乏尊重令人不安。很明显，你不知道“影响力”的力量。它曾服务于你之前的所有市长。它能给你带来巨大的财富和权力，或者也能轻而易举地摧毁你。选择权在你。
You do not consternate me, Vrdolyak. Take this parliamentary maneuver. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
你吓不倒我，弗多利亚克。接下这个议会操纵招式。[模拟激光导弹声音]
Well done, Mayor. But I counter with this negotiated majority. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
干得好，市长。但我用这个协商出的多数派来反击。[模拟激光导弹声音]
Then I file a suit in court. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
那我就向法院提起诉讼。[模拟激光导弹声音]
But the decision is in my favor. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
但裁决对我有利。[模拟激光导弹声音]
[SHRIEKS] You may have prevailed at this juncture, Vrdolyak, but I will assiduously pursue your disestablishment.
[尖叫] 你可能在这个节点上占了上风，弗多利亚克，但我会锲而不舍地追求你的垮台。
[LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING] Perhaps, Mayor. But to do so, you must use the dark side of the clout. You must make deals and compromises.
[沉重的呼吸声] 也许吧，市长。但要做到这一点，你必须利用“影响力”的黑暗面。你必须做交易和妥协。
Never.
绝不。
Yes, Mayor. To defeat me, you must become me. Look at my face, Skytalker, for I am your mentor.
是的，市长。要打败我，你必须成为我。看看我的脸，天行者，因为我是你的导师。
No.
不。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Even under these adverse conditions, Washington did manage to pass budgets and get some things done. Black wards finally got the same street repair and garbage pickup is all the other words. Jacky Grimshaw describes one scheme Washington came up with to do some improvements around the city, designed to be, of course, fairer than fair, to give every word the same benefits. But the 29, of course, opposed it. And Washington needed their approval because to pay for it, he wanted to issue a city bond.
即使在这些不利条件下，华盛顿确实设法通过了预算并完成了一些事情。黑人选区终于得到了与其他选区相同的街道维修和垃圾清理服务。杰基·格里姆肖描述了华盛顿想出的一个改善全市状况的方案，当然设计得“比公平更公平”，让每个选区获得相同的利益。但那29人当然反对它。华盛顿需要他们的批准，因为为了支付这笔费用，他想发行市政债券。
So every ward was to get-- I think it was 10 miles of street resurfacing and a certain number of alleys done and street lighting. And so he had all these on the bond issue, and they were refusing to pass it. So he put all of the reporters on a bus. And he would go around to these various wards. And we went out to Mount Greenwood, another area of the city that did not welcome Blacks at the time, to say, your alderman is refusing to support this bond issue that I want to use to give you real streets. And if you want it, you better tell your alderman to vote for it.
所以每个选区都要获得——我想是10英里的街道重新铺设、一定数量的巷子清理和街道照明。所以他在债券发行中列入了所有这些项目，但他们拒绝通过。于是他把所有记者带上一辆公交车。他会去这些不同的选区。我们去了芒特格林伍德，城市里另一个当时不欢迎黑人的地区，去说，你们的议员拒绝支持我想用来给你们真正街道的债券发行。如果你们想要，最好告诉你们的议员投票支持它。
And so by the time he got through doing this, the folks in the communities were pretty much outraged. Black mayor or not, they wanted their streets. They wanted their sewers. They wanted their vaulted sidewalks repaired and so forth.
所以当他做完这些时，社区里的人们几乎都非常愤怒。不管是不是黑人市长，他们想要他们的街道。他们想要他们的下水道。他们想要他们的拱形人行道被修复等等。
What happens to American politics when one of the politicians happens to be Black? In this case, what happened was that everything in city politics was seen through the prism of race, even though often it had nothing to do with race. Often, it had more to do with reform. Gary Rivlin is the author of a very evenhanded history of Washington's ears, Fire on the Prairie.
当政客中有人是黑人时，美国政治会发生什么？在这种情况下，发生的事情是城市政治中的一切都透过种族棱镜被看待，尽管它通常与种族毫无关系。它往往更多地与改革有关。加里·里夫林是一本关于华盛顿岁月的非常公正的历史书《草原上的火》的作者。
Everyone wants to understand Harold Washington is the first Black mayor. And it's true. He's the first Black mayor. And that was a very significant thing. But he was also the mayor who beat the Chicago political machine. He was the first reformer in 30 years to take on the machine. And he did it more successfully than anyone else before him, purely on a reform point of view. And so he was a different kind of politician. But no one could ever see beyond his race.
每个人都想理解哈罗德·华盛顿是第一位黑人市长。这确实是事实。他是第一位黑人市长。那是一件非常重要的事情。但他也是打败芝加哥政治机器的市长。他是30年来第一位挑战机器的改革者。他比他之前的任何人更成功地从改革的角度做到了这一点。所以他是一个不同类型的政客。但没有人能超越他的种族来看待他。
In fact, there was a political cartoon at the time I loved. And it was an editor asking the reporter covering the election, so, anything change? Anything new? And the reporter answered, nope, he's still white, and he's still Black. And it really wasn't that much more sophisticated than that cartoon indicated.
事实上，当时有一幅我喜欢的政治漫画。编辑问报道选举的记者，“那么，有什么改变吗？有什么新鲜事吗？”记者回答说，“没有，他还是白人，而且他还是黑人。”这真的没有比那幅漫画所暗示的复杂多少。
You pick up a local paper, and these guys just wax so eloquent. They don't know what they're talking about, don't have the slightest idea about the phenomena, don't understand the history, don't understand the mindset, don't understand what push people. All they say is, gee, Black folks must be angry.
你拿起一份当地报纸，这些家伙写得那么雄辩。他们根本不知道自己在说什么，对这种现象毫无头绪，不了解历史，不了解心态，不了解推动人们的东西。他们只会说，“哎呀，黑人们肯定很生气。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Gee, Black folks vote for Black folks. They must hate white folks. That ain't got nothing to do with nothing, nothing, crazy stuff. That's what you read around here in Chicago. That's what I have to put up with every day when I look in the reporters' eyes, all those silly business. How many white folks did you convert today, Harold?
“哎呀，黑人们投票给黑人。他们肯定讨厌白人。”这跟什么都扯不上关系，什么都扯不上，疯了。这就是你在芝加哥读到的。这就是我每天看记者眼睛时必须忍受的，所有那些愚蠢的事情。“你今天策反了多少白人，哈罗德？”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wow.
哇。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Wow. And the answer is more than you did, boy. Because I do my job, irregardless of race, color, creed, and sex.
哇。答案是比你多，伙计。因为我不论种族、肤色、信仰和性别，都在做我的工作。
Because everything he did, even things that were more about reform than about race, was seen through the lens of race, it gave Washington's opponents a tool that they could use against him, which they did. A typical example-- some crime rates went up between 1985 and '86, even though overall, crime was lower under Washington than under his white predecessor. But his opponents tried to make the case that this proved the Black mayor did not care about crime. Hate literature had said that he would do nothing about crime because most crime is caused by Blacks.
因为他所做的一切，即使是那些更多关于改革而不是种族的事情，也被透过种族的视角来看待，这给了华盛顿的对手一个可以用来对付他的工具，他们确实这么做了。一个典型的例子——1985年到86年间某些犯罪率上升，尽管总体而言，华盛顿执政期间的犯罪率低于他白人前任执政期间。但他的对手试图辩称，这证明黑人市长不关心犯罪。仇恨宣传品曾说，他会对犯罪无所作为，因为大多数犯罪是由黑人引起的。
So they were using this statistical bump between '85 and '86 to prove what the hate literature was saying, that the Black mayor's going to be indifferent to crime. See, that's playing the race card and playing it in a dirty way. It's a way of distorting statistics to play to racial fears out there.
所以他们利用这85年到86年间的统计波动来证明仇恨宣传品所说的话，即黑人市长会对犯罪漠不关心。看，这就是在打种族牌，而且打得很脏。这是一种歪曲统计数据以利用种族恐惧的方式。
So did Washington talk about race? Did he talk about the Chicago political machine always being biased against the Black community? Sure. Is that playing the race card? Sure. But I also happen to think it's true, what he was saying, whereas what I think the opposition was doing much more of was playing the race card and playing it in a dirty way, trying to tweak and abuse statistics any way they could to prove their point and play into the worst fears of the white community. I never saw Washington playing into the worst fears of the Black community. In fact, his rhetoric was, I'm going to be fairer than fair.
那么，华盛顿谈论种族了吗？他谈论了芝加哥政治机器总是对黑人社区有偏见吗？当然。那是在打种族牌吗？当然。但我碰巧认为，他说的是事实，而我看到的反对派更多是在打种族牌，而且打得很脏，试图以任何方式调整和滥用统计数据来证明他们的观点，并迎合白人社区最坏的恐惧。我从未见过华盛顿迎合黑人社区最坏的恐惧。事实上，他的言论是，“我要比公平更公平”。
The fact is, by the time he died, just a few months into his second term of office, Harold Washington had put together a working majority on the council. Not many more whites voted for him in his second election than in his first. But every political observer in Chicago says that he was making headway. Patrick O'Connor was one of the 29 alderman who opposed Washington that was one of the few swing votes who sometimes sided with the mayor.
事实是，在他去世时，离他的第二个任期仅几个月，哈罗德·华盛顿已经在议会建立了一个工作多数派。在他第二次选举中，投票给他的白人并不比第一次多多少。但芝加哥的每一位政治观察家都说，他正在取得进展。帕特里克·奥康纳是反对华盛顿的29名议员之一，也是少数有时站在市长一边的摇摆票之一。
We invited him up to a picnic in our ward. And he showed up at our picnic. And he got a great reception. People that really didn't vote for him, and probably wouldn't vote for him the next time, respected the fact that he came out there, that he wanted to say hello, that he wanted to participate. And bear in mind that I was voting consistently with a block that was voting against him. And he came out, and we spent the day, and it was fine.
我们邀请他去参加我们选区的野餐。他出现在我们的野餐会上。他受到了热烈的欢迎。那些实际上没投票给他，并且可能下次也不会投票给他的人，尊重他来到那里、他想打个招呼、他想参与这一事实。请记住，我一直在投票反对他的集团中。但他来了，我们共度了一天，一切都很好。
I remember, one time, we were both invited to a place that neither of us were particularly popular in the ward. And so I got a call from his office-- and this is, again, at a time when there was a counsel war going on-- asking, was I going to this festival or whatever it was? And if I was, would I meet the mayor on a corner in our ward and go in there together with him? And I told the guy, no, I'm not meeting him on the corner. I said, he wants me to go, he's going to pick me up at my house.
我记得，有一次，我们俩都被邀请去一个我们两人在选区中都不是很受欢迎的地方。我接到了他办公室的电话——这是在议会战争期间——问我是否要参加这个节日什么的？如果我要去，我能否在选区的一个拐角处见市长，然后和他一起走进去？我告诉那个人，不，我不会在拐角处见他。我说，他如果想让我去，就得在我家接我。
So the mayor pulls up to the front of my house. He comes in. We have-- a glass of wine, he had, and I had a beer. We sat around for a couple of minutes. And he met my family. And he looks in my dining room. We didn't have any dining room furniture at the time. The kids were all young, and we'd just moved into the house. So he says, where's your dining room furniture? My wife says, you don't pay him enough money. And Harold goes, I knew this cheese was going to cost me something. And he was just that quick. He was really very, very good.
所以市长把车开到我房前。他进来了。我们喝了点——他喝了杯红酒，我喝了杯啤酒。我们坐了一会儿。他见了我家人。他看了看我的餐厅。我们当时没有任何餐厅家具。孩子们都很小，我们才刚搬进那所房子。所以他说，“你的餐厅家具在哪儿？”我妻子说，“你给他的钱不够。”哈罗德说，“我就知道这块奶酪会让我花点钱。”他反应就是那么快。他真的非常好。
But my point is, is that we got in the car. We went to this festival. And by the time he left, he had people dancing with him. He went over. He was talking with folks. By the time he left, it might not have changed the mind of everybody in there, that he was OK, but he made a significant impact. And he understood, by keeping that schedule and going through areas where he was not expected to show up or would traditionally not be the most welcome person, that he was winning percentages of people. And that's all he had to do.
但我的意思是，我们上了车。我们去了那个节日。到他离开时，人们已经在和他跳舞了。他走过去。他在和人们交谈。到他离开时，他可能并没有改变那里每个人的想法，认为他还可以，但他产生了重大的影响。他明白，通过保持那个日程并走进那些他不被预期出现，或者传统上并非最受欢迎的区域，他正在赢得一部分人。而他只需要做到这一点。
Vernon Jarrett says that if Washington had lived, he would have done a lot to ease the strains of modern Chicago apartheid.
弗农·贾雷特说，如果华盛顿活着，他将为缓解现代芝加哥种族隔离的紧张局势做很多事。
Harold was going to win over a big chunk of the white population. And I don't mean Gold Coast liberals. They were beginning to like this guy. And they could see something in him that represented them. He was chubby, warm, friendly. And not only that, he was going into some lower-class white neighborhoods, having their streets paved for the first time. And they were slowly beginning to lose their fear.
哈罗德本来会赢得一大部分白人人口。我不是指黄金海岸的自由派。他们开始喜欢这个家伙了。他们可以在他身上看到某种代表他们的东西。他胖乎乎的，热情，友好。不仅如此，他还走进了一些下层白人社区，首次为他们的街道铺设路面。他们开始慢慢失去恐惧。
Act Two, "The Present and the Future."
第二幕，“现在和未来。”
There are ways, I think, that the mayor has changed the city forever, but they're not things you can necessarily measure by doing headcounts and using a lot of numbers.
我认为，市长以永远改变了城市的方式改变了它，但这些不是你可以通过统计人数和使用大量数字来测量的东西。
Laura Washington, Harold's former press secretary, now editor at a sort of muckraking publication called The Chicago Reporter.
劳拉·华盛顿，哈罗德的前新闻秘书，现在是一家名为《芝加哥记者》的所谓揭黑出版物的编辑。
I think he opened up the city in ways that it will never be closed again. If you look at the numbers, you'll still see a lot of inequity. You'll still see neighborhoods that are poorer, probably poorer than they were 15, 20 years ago. You'll see neighborhoods that still probably don't get their fair share of city services. But you'll see, I think, a dramatic difference in the attitude the public officials and policymakers have to equity in the city.
我认为他以这种方式开启了城市，它将永远不会再被关闭。如果你看这些数字，你仍然会看到很多不平等。你仍然会看到比15、20年前可能更贫穷的社区。你会看到可能仍然没有获得市政服务公平份额的社区。但我想，你会看到公共官员和政策制定者对城市公平的态度有显著的不同。
10 years after Harold Washington's death, people who follow politics in Chicago say that, if nothing else, the current mayor, Richard M. Daley, son of Richard J, has to worry about making Black voters angry. He's been careful to have Black press secretaries and kept a number of appointees from the Black administration before him. He's done nothing so far to infuriate Black Chicago the way his white predecessors regularly did.
哈罗德·华盛顿去世10年后，追踪芝加哥政治的人们说，至少，现任市长理查德·M·戴利，理查德·J之子，必须担心让黑人选民生气。他小心翼翼地安排了黑人新闻秘书，并保留了前任黑人行政当局的一些任命人员。到目前为止，他还没有像白人前任那样经常让芝加哥黑人感到愤怒。
City services are distributed more fairly, even today. There's been a bit of backsliding here and there. And Richard Daley's latest proposed bond issue follows the model of the Washington years. It gives all of Chicago's wards equal benefits, something that was unheard of in the years before Washington.
即便在今天，城市服务分配得也更公平。虽然有些地方有倒退。理查德·戴利最近提议的债券发行遵循了华盛顿年代的模式。它给予芝加哥所有选区相同的利益，这在华盛顿之前的年代是闻所未闻的。
It's been 10 years since Harold Washington's death. And the nation's three largest cities-- New York, Chicago, Los Angeles-- no longer have Black mayors. This is partly a coincidence, no viable candidates in the right positions. Mayor Bradley in Los Angeles stepped down from office. Mayor Dinkins in New York was simply not a strong citywide candidate. Harold had a heart attack. White and Black politicians in Chicago agree that, had Harold Washington lived, he could have stayed mayor, as he often joked, for 20 years. We would be in our 14th year of his administration right now.
哈罗德·华盛顿逝世已经10年了。美国三大城市——纽约、芝加哥、洛杉矶——不再有黑人市长。这部分是巧合，在适当的职位上没有合适的候选人。洛杉矶的布拉德利市长辞职了。纽约的丁金斯市长根本不是一个强有力的全市候选人。哈罗德心脏病发作了。芝加哥的黑人和白人政客都认为，如果哈罗德·华盛顿活着，他本可以像他常开玩笑说的那样，当20年的市长。我们现在本应处于他行政管理的第14个年头。
10 years after Harold Washington's death, we have Black mayors in cities with tiny Black populations, like Seattle and Denver and Minneapolis, and Black mayors in cities with big populations, like Washington, DC and Atlanta. And Michael Dawson, director of the University of Chicago's Research Center for the Study of Race, Politics, and culture, defines the trend this way.
哈罗德·华盛顿去世10年后，我们在黑人人口比例很小的城市，如西雅图、丹佛和明尼阿波利斯拥有黑人市长，在人口众多的城市，如华盛顿特区和亚特兰大也有黑人市长。芝加哥大学种族、政治与文化研究中心主任迈克尔·道森这样定义这一趋势。
Well, there's two types of cities that African-American candidates, or two types of electoral jurisdictions where African-American candidates do very well. Black mayors do well when there's either a very small Black population or a very large Black population and tend to have more difficulty winning in that middle range, where Blacks are viewed as a threat within the city, but where they're not a decisive part of the voting coalition. But in general, when Blacks represent between approximately 15% to 20% of the population to slightly above 50% of the population, that's the most difficult and polarized setting for an African-American to run.
嗯，非裔美国人候选人表现非常好的有两种城市，或两种选举司法管辖区。当黑人人口非常少或非常大时，黑人市长表现很好，而在黑人被视为城市威胁，但并非投票联盟决定性一部分的中间范围时，他们往往更难获胜。但总的来说，当黑人占人口约15%到20%以上至50%以上时，这是非裔美国人参选最困难且两极分化的环境。
When the population is in that range, as it is here in Chicago, when a Black candidate enters the race, it's very hard for him to be seen as anything but the Black candidate. Racial sides are taken, just as happened during Harold Washington's life. And even if the candidate tries to reassure white voters by constantly talking about fairness, by treating them fairly, it can still be enormously difficult to win them over. At the end of Harold Washington's first term, 88% of white voters still voted against him in the re-election.
当人口处于该范围时，正如在芝加哥这里，当黑人候选人参加竞选时，很难不被视为“黑人候选人”。种族阵营被划定，正如哈罗德·华盛顿生前发生的那样。即使候选人试图通过不断谈论公平，通过公平对待他们来安抚白人选民，要赢得他们仍然非常困难。在哈罗德·华盛顿第一个任期结束时，88%的白人选民在连任中仍然投票反对他。
When I asked the people who urged Harold Washington to run in the first place and organized and registered voters-- this is Lu Palmer and Timuel Black-- what the lessons of the Washington years are for us today, they both said the same thing-- to organize. The reason why there's been no Black mayor since Washington, elected here in Chicago, is that the organization that created him vanished once he took office.
当我问那些最初敦促哈罗德·华盛顿参选并组织和注册选民的人——也就是卢·帕尔默和蒂缪尔·布莱克——华盛顿时代对我们今天有什么教训时，他们都说了同样的话——组织起来。自华盛顿以来芝加哥没有选出黑人市长的原因在于，一旦他上任，创建他的组织就消失了。
And I'll tell you, a lot of people don't like to criticize Harold Washington. I blame Harold for this.
我告诉你，很多人不喜欢批评哈罗德·华盛顿。我在这点上责怪哈罗德。
What should have been happening-- we should have anticipated either his demise or removal from office and been organizing for that possibility.
本该发生的事情——我们应该预见到他去世或被免职的可能性，并为那种可能性进行组织。
Harold was put on a pedestal. And I think that was a major mistake. We lifted him to almost god status.
哈罗德被供奉在基座上。我认为那是一个重大的错误。我们将他提升到了几乎神的状态。
10 years later, in most of Black Chicago, this is still how he's seen among people old enough to remember him. But just as it was during his life, after Washington's death, the two Chicagos remember him differently. As to the hearts and minds of white Chicagoans 10 years after the death of Harold Washington and whether they would vote for a Black mayor today, we sent out Rachel Howard on a fact-finding mission to a white ward on the city's northwest side.
10年后，在芝加哥大部分黑人社区，这就是记得他的人们眼中他的形象。但正如他生前一样，华盛顿逝世后，两个芝加哥以不同的方式记住了他。至于哈罗德·华盛顿去世10年后芝加哥白人的内心世界以及他们今天是否会投票给黑人市长，我们派出了雷切尔·霍华德到该市西北区的一个白人选区进行实地调查。
I walked into Fishman and Sons because I liked the sign, red neon letters surrounded by red light bulbs, the biggest sign on the block. This is the 39th Ward, not far from O'Hare Airport, an overwhelmingly white ward that never supported Washington. Inside the bar, the first man I asked about Harold Washington got angry. That nigger, he yelled. What the hell do you want to know about that nigger for? I decided not to ask if he voted for him.
我走进“菲什曼父子”店，因为我喜欢那个招牌，红色的霓虹灯字母被红色灯泡环绕，那是街上最大的招牌。这是第39选区，离奥黑尔机场不远，是一个从未支持过华盛顿的绝大多数白人的选区。店里，我问的第一个关于哈罗德·华盛顿的男人变得愤怒了。“那个黑鬼，”他吼道，“你到底想知道关于那个黑鬼什么？”我决定不去问他是否投了他的票。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[模糊的谈话]
This guy was part of a whole row of men in their late 50s who were eager to talk about Washington, but never on tape. They would start ranting about how he should have stayed on the South Side, how he was a faggot, how he wasn't their mayor. Then, after about a minute, they'd stop, look at me, and say, don't get me started. 10 years is not a very long time. I kept moving around the bar until I finally came to a couple of younger guys in their 40s who let me tape them.
这个家伙是一排50多岁男人的其中之一，他们渴望谈论华盛顿，但从不录音。他们会开始咆哮，说他本该留在南区，说他是同性恋，说他不是他们的市长。然后，大约一分钟后，他们会停下来，看着我，说，“别让我开始说。”10年时间并不算长。我一直在这个酒吧里转悠，直到终于找到两个40多岁的年轻人，他们让我录了音。
No, I didn't vote for Harold at all.
不，我根本没投哈罗德。
Why not?
为什么不？
Because he was Black.
因为他是黑人。
Most people I spoke with felt this way. Some even said they were scared when Harold was elected. And in another bar up the street, a guy explained what everyone had been afraid of.
我交谈过的大多数人都有这种感觉。有些人甚至说，当哈罗德当选时，他们感到害怕。而在街上的另一家酒吧里，一个家伙解释了每个人都在恐惧什么。
We thought, that's it. We're done. And that was a big thing. I mean, North Side's going to be a South Side now. See, the North Side and South Side are very segregated.
我们想，“就是这样了。我们要完了。”那是一件大事。我的意思是，北区现在要变成南区了。你看，北区和南区是非常隔离的。
Put it this way. He thought that--
这么说吧。他认为——
That Black people are going to take over the city.
黑人要接管这座城市。
Not that. Those slums, be slums. You worry about slums.
不是那个。那些贫民窟，变成贫民窟。你担心贫民窟。
This guy was about 35, grew up in the area, still lives there. One of his buddies he was playing pool with, who couldn't stop staring at my breasts, started complaining about Blacks getting more city jobs unfairly. And the first guy cut in.
这个家伙大约35岁，在那个地区长大，现在还住在那儿。他一起打台球的一个伙计，盯着我的胸部看个不停，开始抱怨黑人不公平地获得了更多的城市职位。第一个家伙插话了。
But I tell you what I realized, though, is, you're always worried about race. A Black guy being a Black mayor is like, it doesn't matter. The guy did a lot for us. He did a lot for everybody, not just for white people. I'm going to say he did a lot for everybody, it really made me think that, hey. Unfortunately, I feel bad because I didn't vote for the guy. But after he died and you realize what happened, and the new mayors came in, new regimes came in and all that-- until he died, you finally realize, you know what? He was a damn good mayor.
但我告诉你我意识到什么，不过，你总是担心种族。黑人当黑人市长就像，这不重要。这家伙为我们做了很多。他为每个人做了很多，不只是为白人。我会说他为每个人做了很多，这真的让我觉得，嘿。不幸的是，我觉得很糟糕，因为我没投那个家伙。但当他去世后，你意识到发生了什么，新市长上任了，新政权上任了，所有这些——直到他去世，你终于意识到，你知道吗？他是个该死的好的市长。
The North Side city was a really nice city, white. I mean, I say it's white, but it's a very clean city. And all of a sudden, now we have new streets. Taxes never really went up that much. And it's like, until he was gone, you finally realize, hey, he actually did something for us. My parents say the same thing, goes, son of a gun. He goes, you know what? The best mayor we ever had was Mayor Washington. And you know what, though? We'd never vote for the guy.
北区的城市曾经是一个非常好的城市，白人。我的意思是，我说它是白人，但它是一个非常干净的城市。突然间，现在我们有了新的街道。税收从来没有真正上涨那么多。感觉就像，直到他走了，你才终于意识到，嘿，他确实为我们做了一些事。我父母也说同样的话，说，“哎呀。”他说，“你知道吗？我们曾经拥有的最好的市长是华盛顿市长。”但你知道吗，尽管如此，我们永远不会投票给那个家伙。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[模糊的谈话]
I asked his friend if he thought this too, that things in the ward improved under Harold Washington. He shook his head. He didn't answer.
我问他的朋友是否也这样认为，认为在哈罗德·华盛顿治下，该选区的情况有所改善。他摇了摇头。他没有回答。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[模糊的谈话]
Every group-- if the press is listening, I want them to hear this. They didn't hear it when I ran for office. I'll say it again. Every group, when it gets population ascendancy, as night follows day, decide, without malice to anybody, not angering anybody, that it is their turn, period. That's all. Ain't nothing wrong with that.
每个群体——如果媒体在听，我要他们听到这个。我参选时他们没听到。我再说一遍。每个群体，当它获得人口优势时，就像黑夜跟随着白天一样，决定——不怀恶意对任何人，不惹恼任何人——那是他们的轮次，句号。就这样。这没什么不对的。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I made that statement two months ago, and they said it was racist. But they left out most of the statements, which the Irish do it. And the Polish do it. And the Jews do it. And every intelligent group on Earth, which is every group, does it. And we do it. And we should do it. And we do it in a positive sense, not in a negative sense.
我两个月前发表了那个声明，他们说那是种族主义。但他们略去了大部分声明，那就是爱尔兰人这样做。波兰人这样做。犹太人这样做。地球上每个聪明群体，也就是每个群体，都这样做。我们也这样做。而且我们应该这样做。我们以积极的意义这样做，而不是以消极的意义。
You're not anti-Irish because you're pro-Black. You're not anti-Black because you're pro-Jewish. That doesn't follow. You just happen to be pro. And as long as you are not anti, as long as you are not anti, your pro-ism is acceptable. So it's just that simple. Now I hope the press gets it right just once.
你不会因为你亲黑人而反爱尔兰。你不会因为你亲犹太人而反黑人。那是不合逻辑的。你碰巧就是亲某方。只要你不反，只要你不反，你的亲某方主义就是可以接受的。所以事情就是这么简单。我现在希望媒体能哪怕只有一次把它搞对。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Let's give the last word today to Judge Pincham.
今天最后把发言权交给平查姆法官。
I just happen to be one who believes that, again, the power structure does this-- make heroes out of dead folks-- because dead folks can't lead nobody nowhere. They've made Dr. King a holiday. And he was the most unpopular person at the time of his death of any leader in the history of the nation. And the moment he got killed, since he can't lead nobody nowhere, now he's a hero.
我恰好是相信权力结构这样做的人之一——将死者变成英雄——因为死人哪儿也带不了。他们把金博士变成了一个假期。而在他去世时，他是全国领导人历史上最不受欢迎的人。在他被杀的那一刻，既然他哪儿也带不了，现在他成了英雄。
And Harold?
还有哈罗德？
I don't think that they're going to give Harold the same kind of accolades because he might lead somebody from the grave.
我不认为他们会给哈罗德同样的赞誉，因为他可能会从坟墓里带走某人。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and [INAUDIBLE] Sarah Vowell, production help from Rachel Howard.
嗯，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己制作，南希·厄普代克、亚历克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德，资深编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林，还有[听不清] 莎拉·沃威尔，雷切尔·霍华德协助制作。
We used archival footage today from the following sources-- from Brian Boyer's film, Harold Washington and the Council Wars, which makes its local debut here in Chicago on WTTW in February, from Bill Cameron's taped recordings of Harold Washington's speeches and press conferences. We got tape from Chicago's Museum of Broadcast Communications, thanks to Bruce DuMont and the staff there, also from Howard Gladstone and Jim Ylisela's film, The Race For Mayor, from Bill Stamet's film, Chicago Politics-- A Theater of Power, from WBBM-TV''s Archival news footage.
我们今天使用了来自以下来源的档案片段——来自布莱恩·博耶的电影《哈罗德·华盛顿与议会战争》，该片二月份在芝加哥的WTTW地方首映，来自比尔·卡梅伦录制的哈罗德·华盛顿演讲和新闻发布会。我们得到了来自芝加哥广播通信博物馆的磁带，感谢布鲁斯·杜蒙和那里的员工，也感谢来自霍华德·格拉德斯通和吉姆·伊利塞拉的电影《市长竞选》，来自比尔·斯塔梅特的电影《芝加哥政治——权力剧场》，来自WBBM-TV的档案新闻片段。
WXYT Radio gave us archival tape of Aaron Freeman's Council Wars satire. WTTW-TV gave us archival footage of the 1983 debates. In addition, we'd like to thank Eva Baeza, director of the Chernin Center for the Arts at the Duncan YMCA. Thanks to Gary Rivlin, who gave us advice throughout this production. We recommend his book, Fire on the Prairie. It's a history of the Washington years. His most recent book is called Drive By.
WXYT广播电台给了我们亚伦·弗里曼《议会战争》讽刺剧的档案磁带。WTTW电视台给了我们1983年辩论的档案片段。此外，我们要感谢邓肯基督教青年会切尔宁艺术中心主任伊娃·巴埃萨。感谢加里·里夫林，他在整个制作过程中为我们提供了建议。我们推荐他的书《草原上的火》。这是关于华盛顿岁月的历史。他最近的一本书名为《驾车射击》。
Thanks to Hugo Tyrel and Dolores woods. And thanks to all the people who we interviewed. Every one of them said so much more of interest than we could possibly fit into an hour radio program. If you would like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. The phone number, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
感谢雨果·泰雷尔和多洛雷斯·伍兹。感谢我们采访的所有人。他们每个人说的都比我们能塞进一小时广播节目的内容有趣得多。如果您想购买此节目的卡带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码，312-832-3380。再次重复，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our program has been provided by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting, the John D. and Catherine T. MacArthur Foundation, and the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们节目的资金由公共广播公司、约翰·D·和凯瑟琳·T·麦克阿瑟基金会以及WBEZ芝加哥的听众提供。WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
["CHICAGO" BY FRANK SINATRA] Bet your bottom dollar you lose the blues in Chicago, Chicago
["芝加哥" —— 弗兰克·辛纳屈] 打赌你把你的最后一美元花在芝加哥，芝加哥你就会忘记忧郁。
Let us close out today with a recording from the night of Harold Washington's second mayoral victory.
让我们以哈罗德·华盛顿第二次市长竞选获胜之夜的一段录音来结束今天的内容。
(SINGING) On State Street, that great street, I just want to say
（演唱）在州街，那条伟大的街道，我只想说
They do things they don't do on Broadway
他们做着百老汇不做的事情
They have the time, the time of their life
他们拥有时光，他们一生中最美好的时光
I saw a man
我看见一个男人
He danced with his wife
他和他的妻子共舞
In Chicago, Chicago, my hometown
在芝加哥，芝加哥，我的家乡
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。